uh it's interesting that you start
outing yourself as a mysterianist in a
way right the mysterianism being the
position that human minds are basically
not equipped to understand how they work
or how the universe works that they are
embedded in at a very deep level
and i sometimes joke that mysterianism
is the position that something cannot be
understood if it cannot be understood by
noam chomsky
the norn chomsky is the mysterious with
respect to the mind at the science of
consciousness conference he once uh gave
a presentation where he
talks about the card and then mentions
that the card was actually a very smart
fellow because he could already
anticipate stuff that would only be
discovered much much later on and i was
perking up and wondering my god chomsky
is giving this guy credit
and it turned out what he anticipated
was that
we would later like tomski discover that
the mind is unintelligible
right so uh this
it's fascinating of course if you are
one of the smartest minds of your own
generation and you see that other people
don't understand uh uh things and um
that you understand and there is a
boundary where nobody seems to have an
understanding and you crash against it
you you might think okay maybe there is
no way that humans can do it
not convinced that this is the case
though so i'm not i'm not a
mysteriousness at this point in my
intellectual career
and that's in part because i come from
the other side
so many of the things that
people took as a given for a long time
like space and time
um
appeared to me in the beginning quite
mysterious
so
basically the dissolution of space and
time was not that mysterious to me
basically i'm a computer scientist i
started uh very very early on my life to
program before i properly understood
mathematics and before i understood
physics and i understood how to make
things in a computer and
einstein's watch um that is uh ticking
away and you can observe its
movements and so on but you cannot open
it and you can come up with serious
what's happening inside to me this watch
was the screen of a computer
and i understood that there is no limit
to what can be put into the computer if
it has enough resources right so if the
computer is fast enough enough it has
enough memory there is no pattern that
cannot be shown on the screen there is
no limit to the sequence of patterns
that is to be shown on the screen so any
observation that i am making if i
understand it as a pattern on some kind
of screen that is visible to me i will
always be able to construct something a
mechanism that is on the other side and
produces the sequence
and now the question is can i produce an
elegant sequence can i produce a minimal
pattern can i produce something from
which i think it's plausible that it
emerged by itself
and that is to me this big important
question of physics the idea of
physicalism to me is the notion that
we live in a reality that is fully
emergent over a causally closed
mechanical layer and we are in that base
reality that emerges from it
and the alternatives to physicalism is
that this base layer is somewhere else
because even if we live in a simulation
that is created by some kind of
supernatural being
something must have created the
supernatural being in its parent
universe right so ultimately every
supernatural event is going to have some
kind of natural cause some kind of prime
mover that is ticking away in the void
and producing the patterns that you
observe and the patterns that you
observe are so damn regular and there is
all this conservation going on
of information that uh it doesn't seem
like a conspiracy to me it seems that
we're not in a simulation it seems that
the idea that consciousness could be
primary to our reality is not true
because consciousness being primary
means that you would have to live in
somebody else's mind that we live in
some kind of conspirational simulation
that somebody has set up for us and
while that is possible and i can
principal not exclude it because there
can be no evidence that can ever be
fully conclusive if somebody sets it up
to deceive me there is no reason for me
to believe it because there are not
enough things happening in my reality
that counteract the notion that i live
in a mechanical universe the few things
that pop up i can still explain this by
faulty memories and
psychosis right so the only thing that
uh needs to be explained and that i was
puzzling people like turing and other
thinkers is there's a possibility that
telepathy is true
if that is would be true right we it
would not be compatible with the vein
which we understand physics right now
and as this question is there a point at
which we have to discard physics fully
and accept that you live in some kind of
simulation in some kind of dream
universe that somebody has set up like a
computer game where you can arbitrarily
break hostility when it's convenient or
is this
something that we need to extend physics
or is it just something where our minds
are playing tricks with us and we know
our minds are playing lots of tricks
with us
so during consider the possibility that
telepathy exists as very real to this to
the point where he included this in his
1950 paper computing machinery and
intelligence where he sketches out the
turing test
and seriously asks
what a turing test would have to involve
or such a system the ability to
be telepathic and if it's not what
difference would it make it doesn't get
to the point where you assess out loud
that
if telepathy is possible you cannot be
sure which of your thoughts and feelings
originate in your own brain they could
come from somewhere else right so
this opens up the door to lots and lots
of things
but uh for the time being
i think that uh the evidence for
telepathy is weak and if uh telepathy
would exist i would be seriously willing
to consider this together with turing uh
this is not clear whether we cannot find
a mechanical explanation for it
but there's always going to be some kind
of computer program that explains the
patterns on the screen
now if we think about space
to me as a
kid that was programming the notion of a
continuous space never made sense
because it's not computable i cannot
write something that is continuous space
and when i try to wrap my mind around
the mathematics
the language broke i was not able to
understand how to make a point that is
infinitely small yet fits together if
you add infinitely many of these points
into a continuum
this just doesn't work right
but it's not a problem to make something
that exactly looks like this it's not a
problem to make a computer game that
looks continuous it's not a computer
game that produces physics that looks
similar to what we can observe at least
in the simplification of course our
computers are extremely inefficient when
it comes to simulating
the substrate layer the quantum
mechanics that we can observe or
a layer below the quantum mechanics if
because quantum mechanics is probably
not the the lowest layer in which
physics plays out it's just the lowest
layer in which we can currently make
observations that we can conceptualize
and this leads us to what you also
mentioned
what is the photon i don't think that
einstein started out with the assumption
that the speed of light is fixed i think
it was a derivation that he made he
concluded that the speed of light is
fixed
and
he basically once he had this conclusion
he had implications for the possible
descriptions of space-time that emerged
because uh when the speed of light is
fixed you end up with some very
interesting paradoxes if you stay in a
newtonian universe right you have this
issue imagine you fly in a very fast
spaceship and you are lighting uh
putting light out of your flashlight
inside of your spaceship
wouldn't the speed of light necessarily
add up to the speed of the spaceship to
an external observer
right so wouldn't this external observer
not need to observe a different speed of
light than the person traveling in a
spaceship and if the speed of light is
constant always
it means
that the thing that now it has to change
is time or space or both
right you can still fix this if you make
sure that the speed of uh time runs in a
different way and this leads us to the
inside that the time and space that we
observe from our own perspective as at
merchant observer and whatever universe
produces us
are interdependent they're not
independent of each other the speed of
light depends on the trajectory that the
nor the speed of time depends on the
trajectory that you are taking through
the universe
and
if you want to think about something
that could be more fundamental
we would say that the photon is a
carrier of a
of the electrolytic force it's a type of
boson which means it can be described as
a certain pattern that has an integer
spin
and it has the property that it
is describing the potential lt for
measuring some electromagnetic
interaction
so if we take space time from the
perspective of the observer it's the set
of locations that can contain
information
and the set of trajectories that the
information can take
and the photon is a model of information
traveling through space-time
and what we have discovered and what
einstein also sometimes suspected
is that space itself cannot be
fundamental
and there were concrete reasons to to
see this because what was discovered uh
during einstein's career even and he was
aware of this discovery was that there
were singularities in spacetime which
means points at where the mathematics of
continuous space breaks down so your
mathematics doesn't work anymore you
have some kind of a division by zero
something unpleasant happens where your
mathematics is no longer valid
and what einstein saw is that we can fix
this by
shifting the singularities around in our
spaces type model
and we can basically put them below the
carpet
you can put them in centers of mass
so in the center of mass there is
basically something like little black
hole where mathematics doesn't work
anymore the mathematics of space time
when your mathematical description of
that world doesn't work anymore
and what could be more fundamental than
space-time i think it could be
transitions so you describe the universe
as some kind of state vector a set of
information and this information is
dynamic you have the way in which
information
moves between the locations
and in this paradigm the speed of light
could be
the rate at which information propagates
between locations
and this would be an upper limit of all
interactions that we observe
within this
lattice where stuff is densely connected
what would it what would be necessary to
if you have a set of locations some kind
of graph a causal graph and information
flowing between them to understand that
there is causal structure well you need
to understand where the information
comes from to understand what it
signifies so you can model it
how can a single bit mean anything to
you if it's just a single bit if it's
not attached with the source with the
type with the context
right so what could be a way to figure
out where information comes from well it
needs to have some kind of momentum some
kind of direction
to carry information about direction
and you send this to the graph that by
itself just has just locations
connections the only way that you can do
this is if this thing is extended if
it's not just a single location so which
the information propagates but if it's
neighboring connections and you get
information that verifies it so you need
to have be in some kind of densely
strung lattice for information that you
can pinpoint
basically you need to have something
that looks like a continuous space so
you can identify controllable structure
that you can identify where
uh stuff comes from like a photon
and if there is information that is
traveling across distance so to speak
that is non-local that is not going
through densely connected local
connections but that is going over
individual long range links this
information will look like a random
fluctuation or a distant entanglement
that you can no longer track if you
don't know where it originated
and this will look like something like
in determinism in from your local
observer perspective
still you would uh not be in
contradiction to the
preservation of information it would
still be a universe in which information
is not invented but in which the amount
of discernible information is constant
and if the universe was not in such a
way that information would be preserved
of course it would not be learnable
because it would mean that the present
state of the universe
is forgetting what happened before in
the universe it gets disconnected the
world line of the universe just gets
disconnected and so from an
epistemological perspective we can only
learn the aspects of the universe that
look like they are conserved if there
are things in the universe that are not
conserved then they will not be
intelligible to us
and of course it's conceivable that the
universe is some kind of automaton that
forgets information
another thing that shows us that
space-time cannot be fundamental besides
um well theorem which destroys the
notion of locality is uh the notion of
the collapse of the wave function
basically this
collapse of the wave function is the
point in the history of an observer
beyond which we cannot obtain a model
of locations of events in time and space
right beyond that point it's no longer
not just that we don't have enough
information to construct it but it makes
no sense anymore to assume that the
photon was at a particular point when it
went to the double slit
right at this point the space-time model
breaks down the space-time model is a
mathematical abstraction that works
relatively well to look at things
happening in the limit but it's not a
model that can be fundamental i think
and uh but i'm not a physicist so i'm
not actually qualified to have these
opinions this is just what it looks like
to me as a computer scientist who tries
to understand the mind and things like
donald that we have to
understand a certain degree of physics
to make sure that our theories of
consciousness are tight and that they
make sense and we have to understand in
which way they could possibly relate to
physics
i'm less convinced that donald that a
deep understanding of physics is
necessary or that physics is going to
teach us about consciousness in part
because i don't think that consciousness
is that mysterious anymore i spent a lot
of
time in my life
thinking that it was mysterious but
seems to be a riddle that can be solved
and uh basically i think that there's
some aspects to consciousness for
instance that you that you're observing
yourself to be observing but
consciousness is
something that is entirely virtual it's
not a physical thing
electrons photons
physical entities neurons brains cannot
be conscious they're just
and
what we can see is that the elements of
our consciousness are not mechanical
they're magical somehow there is magic
happening
and if there is magic happening it means
that it's an a causal structure it's
something that has been made on some
kind of causal loom but that is not
necessarily built in the same mechanical
way as physics is built
it's a story it's a it's a tale being
told by a physical system to itself
and if you think about organisms you
often think of them as physical systems
and they're neither right the organism
doesn't exist it's not the same
if you think about it what exists are
cells that interact with each other and
even the cells don't really exist what
exists are molecules and even the
molecules don't really exist right
they're all layers of descriptions
they're models that we can make because
they are coherent
and they hold to some degree
it might be frazzling out at the
boundaries but there are ways of
thinking about the flow of information
in the universe
and the organism is a coherent pattern
that you observe in the interaction
between cells
and the cells have been set up by
evolution to interact in this coherent
pattern because when they interact as if
they were driven by a single spirit by a
single target by a single telos and if
their behavior is coherent and
consistent that are state building
then they have an advantage over cells
which don't do that and just fail for
themselves because together they can
play longer games
by playing longer games they can occupy
niches in nature that cannot be occupied
by control systems that play shorter
games
and this is the benefit that organisms
have these coordinations between cells
and an organism is a function that
describes this pattern in the cells
and the organism is facilitated by
information processing across cells
among other things
to coordinate its interactions the
organism needs to have something like a
telegraph network by which it's able to
make models of reality and coordinate
them between the cells and coordinate
the behavior of the cells
and in animals this
telegraph system is facilitated in large
part by the nervous system it would not
be necessary that the nervous system
basically every cell type can do this
but if you want to make it fast
you need to have specialized cells that
have a very quick expensive metabolism
and can send information over very long
distances very quickly which other cell
types cannot so neurons are a specific
type of cells that allow
particular kind of information
processing
and this information processing has the
property that they can put stuff on the
screen so it's some kind of computer
it's a thing that can produce arbitrary
sequences of patterns if it discovers a
suitable function to produce them and
implement them in the distributed
networks of cells
and part of what they're doing is that
they create a story about a being that
lives in the outside world
and in our culture we have difficulty
understanding how that is because we
in our culture as a default teach our
kids that what they see is the physical
world
yet the physical world has sounds and
colors and so on only much later we tell
them well it's slightly more complicated
and sounds and color are not actually in
physics
everything that you consider to be
sounds in colors is photons photons make
electromagnetic interaction which let
air molecules push against each other so
they can form regular waves and colors
are
local dimensions that you get
by measuring sampling the frequency of
the electromagnetic spectrum using
different receptor types and making a
model of them using polar coordinates
right so this is something that we don't
tell the story fully to our children
which makes it even more confusing and
then we tell them
photons are actually not little billiard
balls but there are regions in the space
time that have a potential for an
electromagnetic interaction
and this space that you're talking about
is the photonic space
it's the space where you can possibly
have photon interactions for some reason
it's three-dimensional
and maybe there are other spaces that
are not three-dimensional and maybe in
these spaces you cannot have interacting
matter in the same way
because
maybe
in order to get stable objects you need
to make little nuts in the
electromagnetic structure or in the
spatial structure and you cannot make
knots in 2d and in 4d they fall apart so
maybe that's the reason or maybe there's
another one and we haven't completely
figured it out yet and there are some
candidates that explain why the space
that we are in is three-dimensional so
why is it that we are interacting with
the photonic space and not with the
others why are the others not seeming to
form a connected space
in this connected letters
um but we don't know the answer yet at
least i'm not aware of the work that is
sketching out the answer
and
if i stumble on it i i pray that i
understand it
but i think that there are other
cultures that have a better intuitive
understanding of what consciousness is
and if you look around we find that some
cultures don't find consciousness
mysterious i even suspect that in the
core of our own culture before the tower
of people that destroyed the shared
understanding it's still in there
so a little bit obsessed these days with
thinking about genesis in the bible and
read this epistemologically correct not
as a myth that is an uh stand in for an
origin theory until real science comes
along
but as something that is literally true
so what would that mean you know i'm
talking about the first book if i'm
talking about um the book that starts
out with the creation of sky and
darkness and heaven and earth and so on
and
they sing with the story if you take it
literally the way in which christianity
interprets it
it's a story about a supernatural being
creating a physical universe and what's
wrong with the story is that whoever
tells it to you had no evidence that it
was true
right so there is no claim if somebody
makes a claim without evidence you don't
have to listen
it uh it could be interesting as a story
for cultural reference what it could be
interesting as an idea for something
that you could test but if it's
principle not testable
this person cannot have that evidence
there is no secret source of knowledge
that this person had there is in
principle nothing that uh that
some other person can up others with
some kind of back journal by talking to
a burning bush that would constitute a
valid experiment so
this reading makes no sense
it will never make any sense but it
could make sense especially if you
understand that
sky and ground
and light and sound and plants and
animals and their names don't actually
exist in physics
right they only exist in our mind as a
division of the universe into separate
objects so they become intelligible to
us
and the way in which we construct these
objects is inside of the mind so the
creation of the universe that is being
described in genesis is not the
physicalist universe with quantum
mechanics
it's the creation of the experimental
universe in which we are actually in in
which we find ourselves to be in
and the first thing that the mind is
discovering when it creates this
universe is how to make light
right how to uh create neural
oscillators that are creating a contrast
between light and darkness so separate
the light from the darkness and then
organize this into multiple dimensions
until you get a space
and then you align the space with the
information from your vestibular organs
and what you get
is the two-dimensional plane of the
ground and the three-dimensional space
of the sky above it
right so after you create light and
darkness you create literally every mind
does this in the cognitive development
the sky and the ground
and then you discover the objects in it
so you basically learn how to model
materials in your mind so you have
solids and you have liquids
and you have organic shapes and you have
animated agents
and then you discover features that you
cannot interact with like celestial
bodies
and anchor them in the world and you
learn how to navigate this world
and then you discover all the plants and
the animals or you construct them in
your mind and you associate them all
with their names so again of course not
a feature of the physical world they are
socially cons
exchanged these names and so on create
this world together and then
last but not least
be create a person
so the thing that creates it is not a
person yet it's a mind that exists
before a person is around we don't
remember how we made light
we don't remember how we discovered the
sky and the ground in the first space
this was another observing agent in our
own brain and this observing agent in
our own brain at some point discovers
the needs of a person of the needs of an
organism the organism that its brain is
embedded in
and it creates a model of that too so it
creates
an agent
that is observing this universe that is
embedded in this universe because this
first observer in our own mind is
discovering
that such an entity exists it's this
useful model to describe reality that
there is a person that has needs and
desires and social embedding and dreams
and hopes and memories and expectations
and it will create a story of that and
that story is just as real as the trees
that exist in our mind as imaginations
or the trees or um the uh that in the
forest and uh beyond the horizon and uh
as real as the sky and the clouds and
the colors and so on but they're all
virtual they're all simulacra they all
exist to tell a story to the organism
that is useful for the organism to model
the world
and this part where we become a person
seems to be happening i think around the
age of one and a half to two and a half
roughly in most children that i observed
and at this point a person that is
different from before emerges in their
mind it's not that there is nobody there
before it's just that this thing before
is different
and you notice that there is a gap in
their memories they have memories when
they uh in the
first year when you talk to them
where they remember what happened
and have expectations already
but later on there is this point where
they don't remember these things anymore
it's very weird and most people when you
think back don't have memories that they
can consciously access between uh before
they're like two and a half years old
and so i wonder if this transition is
the result of just a re-indexing of
memories due to our newfound linguistic
ability so we can later on no longer
access these memories or if it's really
just basically a new agent that is
created by the first agent in its own
image
as an observer that is aware of the fact
that it's observing
and but in a different way as men and
women as something that thinks it's a
person that thinks it's a human being
and i'm not a human being i realize that
at some level i don't have an identity
as a human being this is a story that my
mind tells itself as an additional thing
my consciousness doesn't have an
identity
my consciousness is also not of the
nature that it's the same as everybody
else's consciousness right it's
the question do we all uh are the same
consciousness looking through different
eyes or with separate consciousnesses is
in some sense as meaningless as the
question of asking is the text editor
that you're running onto your computer
the same text editor that everybody else
runs on their computer
or is it a different one
right uh the program word is in some
sense a natural law if you put the
circuits of your computer in the same
functional configuration then
those things are going to happen with
the circuits of your computer and they
will afford the following interactions
but the program word doesn't have an
identity and it's also not that it has
no identity in the sense it's just not a
meaningful category to apply to it in
the same sense my consciousness is not
in in this category that would have an
identity or none
so it's it's not something that is
shared with others and it's not
something that is separate from others
it's a principle that applies to the
observation and when the consciousness
gets tied to a self-model then it
becomes perspectival and they have an
identity and so on but this identity is
a particular kind of model that my
organism tells itself by changing
certain factors in my own brain